hey how's the gum for us
don't worry about the hoodie it's all
good I did not cut my hair okay don't
worry about my hair it still still blue
steel berg i prom it 100%
don't worry i'm here to talk about
something i've been wanting to talk
about for a very long time pewdiepie
Stuber simulator i thought this game is
coming out the 29th of september it's
gonna be the most badass game you have
ever played do you think you played you
super simulators before well this you
haven't played PewDiePie Stuber
simulator that's right we got around the
Capri right
this game has some development over the
year baby this game is so fresh it's
gonna change your life this game it's
gonna be your new best friend you're in
your pocket Pokemon go more like pokemon
uninstall that install Petey pyres
cuber simulator this game it's the best
game you have ever played on your phone
best game that has ever gained in your
gaming life that sounded legit right
okay great
now you hyped you hyped for this game
same guys that made Peter pie legend of
the brofist the best game in the world
after this game of course this game will
be better than that one
alright let's let's have a look this is
how it looks like hello hey how's the
gum race my name is Pierre de pack there
will be my voice there I'll teach you
how to play the game yeah you start off
with your shitty setup in your shitty
room you make videos there is audio in
the game I just can't record both at the
same time I don't know why but as you
can see you start off and your place
looks like a piece of you're a
broke-ass youtuber and your goal is to
beat me baby your goal is to get more
substance peopIe now we're gonna start
by making a video drinking bleach
tutorial great I did not even set that
up fantastic
cat playing piano dies at age 7 that's a
that's a good second video to start with
so this game plays a little bit like
Nicko at Summa if you play that game you
pick it up you play it for a while you
put it back in your pocket and you check
it about a little bit later you know
it's a really really fun gaming
experience that I really really enjoy
and I think it works perfect for mobile
I've I keep forgetting to click on
sponsor Eagle you can get from him
as you progress your studio will become
cooler better you'll get better
equipment which leads to better videos
and more views and more subscribers you
can move around objects you can put them
wherever you want
this looks I can customize myself
how do I want to look like of course I
want this outfit then cool this
outfit ever sake there's so much
weird in this game you can be a
barrel you can be whatever you
want in this game maybe so here's where
you can buy items for view so you
collect and pimp out your room oh boy
that's a good window oh that that click
on the Eagle that's five subscribers
thank you sponsor Eagle you can choose
to play the game passively like I
mentioned but we also made it so if you
wanna keep playing you have that option
so you can play puggle this is actually
the first time I see the finished
version of this it looks awesome
oh my god it's Edgar hey I got the food
ball hell yeah
there's a skill tree in the game which
lets you strategize strategize how you
want to get more views faster there's
different methods I like to go for
streaming because that way you can gain
views while you're not playing the game
which is pretty cool we call acknowledge
there is a load of items in this
game because this game is supposed to
last you a long time this game is gonna
be your best friend for the next six
months
I'm not kidding so if you don't want to
spend any money in the game you 100%
don't have to that's the thing that
everyone keeps complaining about when we
we made legend in the brofist to be like
yeah it's a cool game I guess but it's
not four years it well here you
go it's free now you could boost while
watching ads don't play those games
though just play my game does it seem
sketchy that I'm sitting over the hoody
introducing this thing yeah you guys you
guys are gonna wreck get real hype to
this so the goal of the game is
obviously to get the more subscribers
but the way you get that is to get more
items and customizing yourself and
that's a huge part of the game which is
the social aspect of it I'll tell you
what that means basically you'll be able
to vote on other people's rooms if you
really like how someone how they
customize that you can vote for them or
you can follow them it's basically like
getting YouTube subscribers they'll be a
ranking of all of this so it's a very
competitive aspect of the game okay I
literally made this in just like a few
minutes so I could pimp it out a lot
more but the idea is basically that no
matter what kind of youtuber you would
like to make or which youtuber you want
to make say here you want to make a
youtuber focus on music or beauty or
gaming or funny videos or creepy videos
you can make that youtuber in this game
and customize your setup accordingly and
I think that's really cool I'm so again
I am so excited for you bros to play
this alright you can definitely get
weird with this game let's just say that
you just gotta keep making videos and
one day you'll be able to beat poopie
pie like I said it's very creative so
I'm really excited to see how you bros
are gonna customize your setup I just
want to say huge thanks to out of mines
for working so hard on this game and
making it the best it can be it has so
many items it has so many cool features
it just feels like such a fun game I am
so excited for you bros to play this and
more and more even that I'm just excited
to see what you bros are gonna make with
this it will be open for everyone to
play yeah yeah I'm so excited
I'm so pumped are you pumped
twenty-ninth let's do this
miss bye
no maybe watch more gay porn